economists have a role to play in
suggesting how we should be possibly
expanding our definition of economic
growth to account for the costs that it
often incurs in terms of climate change
we've made a lot of progress in valuing
the environment in valuing natural
resources as capital assets over the
last 20 or 30 years whether it's
thinking about the value of fish or
thinking about the value of clean air or
thinking about the value of forests or
pollinators famously Bill Nord house
measured how much climate change would
impact the global economy and his
research was part of the reason people
became convinced that this was a real
problem what are the costs of climate
change how much is it going to affect
the economy and how much is it going to
affect people's lives the effects of
more extreme heat and cold is felt more
by the poor in lower inome countries who
have less ability to adapt so it's easy
for the United States or Europe which
are already the richest you know
countries in the world to say well we
ought to move towards uh sources of
energy that use less carbon it's much
harder to say that uh for countries
where most people don't have a car or an
air conditioner or a flat screen TV
economics isn't about money it's about
trade-offs it's about the way people
make decisions that's what's actually
most exciting to me about all of this is
it provides a path forward for us to
work together to solve some of the
biggest challenges we're going to have
to ask questions about what is economic
inequality and how will we deal with it
these issues of inequality and
environmental justice are actually going
to be at the heart of a conference which
looks at issues of climate environment
and economic growth and in particular
what is the future of economic growth
especially for lower income countries
during the climate
[Music]
transition